we've returned to the jungles of
southern beliefs where the Jaguar rules
the night once the ancient Maya's
believed that stars were spots on a big
cats coat at one with the evening sky as
its stalked through the shadows tonight
this fierce proud hunter is stalking a
young crocodile
the Jaguar is the largest and most
powerful cat in the Western Hemisphere
and third-largest overall only lions and
tigers are bigger Jaguars are
comfortable in the water in fact they're
one of the few cats who enjoy water
the average male Jaguar weighs 200
pounds and lives 12 to 15 years in the
wild it's an endangered species mainly
because of the skin trade and habitat
destruction this Jaguar is displaying a
lethal self-confidence as it fishes for
croc not much question who's gonna win
this battle
time to close the deal
it's not hard to see how the Jaguar got
its name
it's from the Guarani Indian word yeah
Guara meaning beast that captures its
prey in a single bound